they're turning the frickin Penguins gay
more specifically they're turning the
Penguins transgender and then giving
them gay penguin parents at an aquarium
in London we will examine a brief
history of the sexual revolution in the
animal kingdom then three pieces of
great news all in a row for the Trump
administration some bad news in the
Democratic primary especially for Joe
Biden as we head into tonight's debate
and finally the mailbag all that and
more I'm Michael Knoll so this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
you know I've been a little under the
weather of the past few days this has
given me more of a gravelly voice and I
wondered I thought Lord why do I have
this sickness on a very busy week then I
realized it was all so that I could
perfect my Alex Jones voice for the
biggest story of the day they are
turning the frickin Penguins gay can we
get Alex Jones up here about the frogs
because I don't like gay people I don't
like putting chemicals in the water to
turn the friggin frogs gay do you
understand that forget the frogs they
are turning the Penguins gay a London
Aquarium has announced that two lesbian
penguins are now going to raise a
genderless penguin chick how is that
possible that you would maybe suggest
there are a few problems with this one
penguins aren't lesbians and two
lesbians can't produce a child and three
despite gender ideology existing in the
Academy and in the mainstream media and
in left-wing politics in the human world
in the animal kingdom our gender
ideologies don't quite apply and the
penguin will either be a male penguin or
a female penguin none of that matters
the way that this is happening is that
the zookeepers or the aquarium keepers
in London have identified two penguins
who spend a lot of time together
both female they've called them lesbians
they then took a egg from another
penguin couple taking it away from its
parents and then given it to these
lesbian penguins and then they're gonna
raise the penguin without any of the
stereotypes of the gendered penguin
society I don't think there are really
any stereotypes and the whole thing
doesn't make a lot of sense it also
before we get to the London Aquarium
trying to defend this bizarre decision I
should point out what the left is
actually doing here is ripping a child
away from its parents and keeping it in
a cage which is the same thing that
we've heard is the worst possible thing
in the world for the past
two years of the Trump administration
there's nothing worse than taking a
child away from its parents and keeping
it in a cage and yet that is exactly
what the left is doing with this poor
would-be genderless penguin and the
lesbians at the London Aquarium that
point is neither here nor there
here is a staff member of the London
Aquarium defending this decision and
explaining how exactly a penguin can be
raised with that agenda what we wanted
to do was to take the opportunity to
raise the whole conversation with guests
who come through to the aquarium just to
raise that at that point that there is a
difference between gender and sex and in
terms of the way that we manage the
colony at the aquarium we wouldn't
manage them differently based on whether
they are females or males what we wanted
to do with this chick was give guests an
opportunity to meet that individual and
learn about its personality without
assigning it any sort of frequencies or
gender roles what gender roles are there
in the penguin Kingdom I mean all
penguins wear tuxedos they don't even
have gender roles in terms of their
clothing they all wear the male clothing
again neither here nor there also what
makes you think that you can take away
the gender roles if there are gender
roles from the Penguins you can't talk
to the Penguins you can't tell the
Penguins to behave a certain way you
can't educate the Penguins they're
penguins they don't have higher
intellect so many errors in what she
said the big error that she begins with
is that there is a difference between
gender and sex this is what we have been
told this is now being taught in first
grade this is being taught all the way
back in our public schooling and in the
popular culture there is no difference
between gender and sex the very fact
that they make this statement so
breathlessly shows you that they don't
have a very good argument here for
basically all of human history there was
sex
what is your sex you can be either male
or female man or a woman then in the in
the popular use of the language about 50
years ago the term gender was introduced
to apply to human beings gender never
really applied to human beings before
gender is a grammatical
term when you're learning a foreign
language you have gendered nouns for
instance masculine and feminine pizza
ends in a that's a feminine noun gato is
a masculine noun ends in an O they they
applied this term to human beings to
create the impression that there is a
difference between sex and gender but
there isn't any actual distinction you
don't just have to take my word for it
you can ask them for this you know one
of the arguments that leftists used to
say that there's a difference because
you'll say what is the difference
between sex and gender they'll say well
sex is biological and gender is socially
constructed but then they immediately
contradict themselves when they say that
the people can be for instance females
born in male bodies women born in men's
bodies or they'll say you know that
their brains are female but the rest of
their bodies are male if that is the
case then gender is not socially
constructed then gender is innate just
like biology right if you're if you are
born as a man inside a woman's body or a
woman inside a man's body then it's not
a social construction of gender
they're both innate they're both with
you from the beginning you didn't choose
to be that way you were born this way
or if you say that you have a male brain
and a female body or vice versa then
again that's not socially constructed
because the brain is biological that's
physical matter so any way you slice it
what they're trying to say is sex and
gender are both biological and sometimes
what they're trying to say is sex and
gender are both socially constructed as
in the case of when you hear these
leftists say that you can have a
biologically female penis or a
biologically male uterus they they can't
reconcile this because they they can't
grant themselves the the notion that
there is such thing as a metaphysical
world or as a soul or as something that
isn't just a matter so any way you slice
it on their own arguments there is no
difference between sex and gender and I
know that this is being taught
everywhere the best way to confront this
argument is just ask them what's the
difference
and then when they say well one is
socially constructed you say well what
if you're born this way if you're born
this way it's not socially constructed
what if you have a male brain in the
female body it will break down that
argument breaks down this tells us quite
a lot the reason I bring up the Penguins
obviously I don't really care about the
sexual habits of penguins but the way
that we human beings treat sex in the
animal kingdom tells us a lot about how
we treat sex among ourselves and this
has been going on a long time and
coincidentally penguins for some reason
are always the subjects we use going
back to the gay penguins so-called of
the 1990s we'll get to that in one
second then we'll get to great news for
the Trump administration but first I
have got to talk about one of my
favorite products oh listen
this time I sound like I'm a little sick
because I caught a cold
sometimes I sound like I'm a little sick
because maybe I had a late night the
night before okay the the other day
sargon of akkad was in town i had the
misfortune of going out drinking with an
englishman and that doesn't turn out
well for Americans the English can drink
you under the table introducing a liquid
IV liquid IV is the fastest most
efficient way to stay hydrated now good
responsible people use liquid IV because
in the summer you get dehydrated you're
outside and you want to stay hydrated
good responsible people use liquid IV
because they're athletes you know it's
really excellent for athletes who are
constantly expending a lot of energy and
they're sweating a lot
that's not me I'm not really an athlete
so the thing I really like about it for
is if maybe I have a little bit of a
late night maybe you know I go to a
bachelor party or something
liquid IV is there and I'm telling you
man it works just generally if you're
trying to drink more water liquid IV
will help you there to hydrates two to
three times faster and more efficiently
than water alone with an added bonus of
vitamins C b3 b5 b6 and b12 it really
works I'm always skeptical of these kind
of products I tried tried it the other
day it's just tremendous luckily I got a
number of boxes of it I'm recommending
it to all my friends it's really great
you know even on nights where I don't go
out and have a few Coca Cola's with the
boys just generally I don't drink
water it's it's one of my flaw I don't
know I just drink either coffee or tea
or something it's a wonderful way to
stay hydrate you feel like you got more
energy it's great look what ivy is the
fastest-growing wellness brand you can
find them everywhere even at Costco you
can find their hydration multiplier and
all Costco's nationwide liquid ivy can
provide the same hydration as drinking
two to three bottles of water
I love liquid ivy I know you will too
right now my listeners get 25% off at
liquid ivy dot-com when you use my code
Knowles cane or wles
at checkout that's 25% off anything you
order on liquid Ivy's website go to
liquid IV dot-com enter promo code
Knowles to get your savings start
getting better hydration liquid IV
dot-com promo code Knowles don't wait
start properly hydrating today back in
the 90s the late 90s 1998 or so we began
to hear about two gay penguins at the
Central Park Zoo Roy and silo they were
the talk of the town
the New York Times eventually started
writing columns about them especially by
2003-2004 if they titled one of the
columns one of the articles rather the
love that dare not squeak its name they
talked about how Roy and silo were
inseparable they had no interest in
female penguins they had sex with each
other I mean a lot more than you ever
wanted to know about these penguins all
of a sudden gay penguins started
cropping up all over the place everyone
started seeing gay penguins they said
this is totally normal you see this
threat the whole animal kingdom they
ended up at the Central Park Zoo taking
an egg from another couple and giving it
to Roy and silo to raise and that
penguin became tango and then they said
the tango was a lesbian penguin and so
on and so forth they burst out of the
headlines though the following year in
2005 when Roy and silo apparently broke
up and silo shacked up with a lady
penguin apparently nature won out in the
end for silo after that even the New
York Times admitted no one ever actually
saw Roy and silo have sex there's no
evidence that they were actually a
couple or or anything like that the New
York Times admitted they were
anthropomorphizing
they
were reading into the Penguins what we
were seeing and what we wanted to see in
our human society I think it's no
coincidence that Roy and silo magically
appeared onto the scene as gay penguins
the exact same year that Will and Grace
premiered on network television and that
premiere of Will & Grace was kind of a
cultural marker of the mainstreaming of
homosexuality in the American public
consciousness and popular culture we
then reflect that in the animal kingdom
and we're seeing the same thing with
gender ideology now 20 years later all
of a sudden now we're seeing genderless
penguins transgender penguins and of
course there's no such thing as a
transgender penguin because even by the
own language of the left/right you have
your sex which is natural and then you
have your gender identity which is a
matter of self perception penguins don't
have self perception I don't talk to
penguins I can't really know their
thoughts that's sort of the point
penguins don't have language we can't
communicate with them penguins do not
have consciousness they do not have the
higher intellect they do not have free
will which is what separates human
beings from animals we are simply
superimposing our own new bizarre views
on gender on to these animals you know
you you need a higher intellect as only
humans have in order to even come up
with so irrational a concept as
transgender ideology even you know
people make fun of Alex Jones right Alex
Jones said they're turning the freaking
frogs can we just get that again I just
really I want to hear the precision of
his argument do you understand that you
know people made fun of Alex Jones for
saying that they're turning the frickin
frogs gay and it is true he didn't get
that quite right but ironically what
nobody knows is the thing that he got
wrong in his analysis is that he didn't
go far enough it turns out they weren't
turning the fricking frogs gay they were
turning the frickin frogs transgender in
a certain sense there were these
chemicals in the water in the ponds in
Connecticut that were turning the frogs
I guess you'd say hermaphroditic they
had Bo
with male and female reproductive cells
so they had sperm and they had eggs in
them was something like 1 in 8 frogs
that were being investigated by Yale
researchers EPA appointed Yale
researchers in Connecticut so the irony
here and he'll never get credit for it
is that Alex Jones actually was sort of
modest in his analysis of what was going
on with the frogs and he didn't go far
enough
but even even in that case where you you
have these chemically induced
deformities in the frogs even that is
not transgenderism it's a kind of
strange biological quirk that's going on
because of chemicals in the frogs but a
concept a concept such as transgenderism
or homosexuality or whatever is
essentially human you you see that these
concepts and the meaning that we impose
on those and the way that that meaning
changes over time as our culture
reinterprets these ideas and comes comes
to new understandings is human it's
silly it's ridiculous it doesn't tell us
about the Penguins it doesn't tell us
about the frogs it's pretty funny to
think that we're talking about lesbian
penguins and transgender frogs and all
those things it doesn't tell us about
the animals what it tells us is about
the psyche of the zookeepers themselves
and what it tells us is is the cultural
understanding and the psychological
strangeness of the people the societies
the culture who are looking at those
animals when we're looking at those
penguins and those frogs and seeing all
sorts of strange things we're really
looking at is a mirror and we're seeing
ourselves well let's get off of gay
penguins for a second and let's get to
much more important political news huge
three back-to-back wins for the White
House and for Republicans and really bad
timing because we have this big
democratic debate tonight we'll get to
that in a second but first support for
the Michael Noel's show comes from our
friends and rocket mortgage by Quicken
Loans I live in Los Angeles very
difficult to find a house it's actually
not hard to find a house it's it's hard
to find a house that's less than like
seven zillion dollars and they're all
these arcane regulations and it's just
really frustrating in LA
I dunno though when I find a house at
least finding the right mortgage will be
easy because rocket mortgage makes it
easy their mortgage experts number-one
goal is to make the home buying process
smoother for you
industry-leading online lending
technology rocket mortgages there with
award-winning client service and support
every step of the way you know buying a
house is going to be probably the most
important financial decision you ever
make in your life so when you're making
it why go in with anything less than the
best what you can do with rocket
mortgage by Quicken Loans you can go in
to the number one ranked highest in
customer satisfaction for primary
mortgage origination nine years in a row
and the highest and mortgage servicing
six years in a row this is especially
important I think for younger buyers or
first-time buyers because I being a
millennial myself never learned anything
useful I don't know anything about the
mortgage process I don't know anything
about balancing my own checkbook
fortunately when you work with rocket
mortgage by Quicken Loans you get more
than just alone because rocket mortgage
is more than just a lender get started
online at rocket mortgage comm slash
Knolls Canada wles Equal Housing lender
license for all 50 states nmls consumer
access door number 30 30
rocket mortgage by Quicken Loans push
button get mortgage let's get on to some
important political news here great news
down at the southern border the wall is
being built we have wall at least 60
miles of new wall currently being built
we have proof of this from Customs and
Border Protection that's the same
Customs and Border Protection that just
a month or two ago came out and said
that not one inch of new wall has been
built now we have drone footage we can
see with our own eyes we've got 60 miles
of new wall being built which is good I
mean that is basically about 10 percent
of the currently existing wall we have
about 650 miles or so of currently built
wall and so if you add another 60 to
that you're upwards near near 10% of
what already exists and they're looking
forward to a lot more CBP said they
expect to build 450 miles
wall before the year is out and you
might say that sounds ambitious yeah it
could be ambitious though we did the
math on this show about a week ago
between the the new amount of money it
was two and a half billion dollars the
Trump was able to get from the Pentagon
because of that new Supreme Court ruling
between that and I think another 3.6
billion dollars the Trump was able to
get and to divert from other projects
into building the wall if you look at
the cost per mile it looks as though
Trump could get up to nine hundred
some-odd even up to eleven hundred miles
of wall total which is a comes out to a
total of about 450 new miles of wall
it looks like they're actually on track
for that this would be huge huge with a
why to use the president's word and what
it shows you is not just the importance
of sound immigration policy not just the
importance of persistence it shows you
the importance of the judges we would
not have gotten this wall if the Supreme
Court in a 5-4 decision that would have
been a 7-2 decision if Hillary Clinton
had won that election and appointed left
wing judges in a 5-4 to every way I
guess it would've been a 6-3 decision
probably against Trump all right I guess
it wouldn't be against Trump there
wouldn't be any decision in the first
place they wouldn't be trying to build
the wall because Hillary would be in
charge of the government but even
whenever you get to the next Republican
president we would have lost at the
court because of the judges and if we
lost at the court that two and a half
billion dollars goes away who knows how
many other judicial decisions would have
gone away the courts mattered and the
courts mattered
therefore the election mattered 2016 had
to get a Republican in there not just on
building the wall but on immigration
more broadly you know there was a big
decision came out from asylum today in a
72 decision from the Supreme Court
Ginsburg and Sotomayor dissenting the
Supreme Court upheld the
administration's ability to
reduce the number of people seeking
asylum at the southern border so right
now one of the big ways into the country
is you've got economic migrants coming
through some of them have kids many of
them aren't even their own kids and they
come through and they say okay we got
caught we got pinched we are going to
claim asylum in America we came from El
Salvador Honduras or wherever wat Amala
now we're going to claim asylum except
they don't really need asylum their
economic migrants what this new rule
does that the White House said if you
leave your country because you're
fleeing violence and then you pass
through another country for instance
Mexico without claiming asylum there
first and you just try to get it in the
United States you will be automatically
rejected for your asylum claim because
obviously you're not really seeking
asylum you're seeking a way better life
in America because America is way better
than Mexico I don't even blame the
people who are coming through who say
okay I'm gonna use a fake asylum claim
or I'm gonna skip over Mexico because I
really want to end up in America I don't
blame them I would probably do the same
thing that's all fine the United States
has a right to protect its own borders
the citizens of the United States have a
right to their own country the citizens
of the United States have a right to
make our own laws we are a democratic
republic we get to govern ourselves
there are economic migrants coming up
from Central and South America they're
pursuing their interest fine
we have a national interest and we have
something to protect if we don't protect
our country there's no country to flee
to in the first place this is a great
rule coming out of the White House and
it made it all the way up to the Supreme
Court because of an interesting history
at the courts so at the federal level at
the district court an Obama appointed
federal judge John Tiger based in San
Francisco tells you everything you need
to know blocked the rule tiger wrote
quote while the public has a weighty
interest in the efficient administration
of the immigration laws at the border it
also has a substantial interest in
ensuring that the statutes enacted by
its representatives are not imperiled by
executive Fiat and he said that
rules stopping this new White House
policy would vindicate the public's
interest which our existing immigration
laws clearly articulate in ensuring that
we do not deliver aliens into the hands
of their persecutors so basically what
he said is yeah you want to enforce
immigration law but I don't want to and
so you're not going to let you do that
sure yeah we have laws about keeping
foreign nationals out of our country and
not letting them invade our country and
not letting them cross into the border
illegally sure we have that but we also
have laws about asylum so let's just
forget all the first laws and we'll only
have the second laws now you might be
asking how did it make it all the way up
to the Supreme Court because it first
went to the ninth district court of
appeals and the most liberal court in
the land right hmm not so much anymore
how did the most liberal court in the
land stop being the most liberal court
in the land we'll get to that in one
second but first I have got to thank
another wonderful sponsor Horace Mint
Mobile in the bad old days I even until
recently I had a big cell service big
cell phone companies charge you whatever
they want to charge you that's it it's
impossible to know what you're paying
for they have those tiny little hidden
fees that are not so tiny when you add
them up no more thanks to Mint mobile
you know I've had multiple phones at
different points in my life for personal
use I love mint mobile mint mobile
provides the same premium network
coverage you're used to at a fraction of
the cost there is no reason not to head
over there mint Mobile makes it easy to
cut your wireless bill down to just 15
bucks a month I know what you're saying
there's no way that's possible 15 bucks
a month no it's gonna be 15 plus this
and that listen tit 15 bucks a month
every plan comes with unlimited
nationwide talking text with mint mobile
you how does it work you stop paying for
unlimited data this is how big tech gets
you for a big big cell phone rather they
say okay we're gonna give you here's the
base rate and we're gonna charge all
these fees but then you'll get unlimited
data but you know you don't use the
unlimited data so with mint mobile you
get between either three eight or twelve
gigabytes
4g LTE data most of the time you're on
Wi-Fi anyway in the office at your house
use your own phone with any minute
mobile plan keep your same phone number
along with all your existing contacts
ditch your old wireless bill start
saving with mint mobile it's incredible
it's a wonderful product get your new
wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
get the plan shipped to your door for
free go to mint mobile comm slash
Knowles canna wles mint mobile comm
slash Knowles canna wles
cut your wireless bill down to 15 bucks
a month mint mobile comm slash Knowles
so district-level court obama appointed
judge stops the trump rule on asylum
then goes to the 9th district court of a
Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals bad news
right that's the most liberal court in
the country Ninth Circuit actually
tightened up judge Tigers decision and
said that Judge Tigers decision would
only apply to Arizona and California so
it actually allowed the white house rule
to work in New Mexico and Texas that's
pretty interesting
now that circuit actually helped out the
Trump administration then it goes to the
Supreme Court Supreme Court gave the
white house permission to issue the rule
nationwide this is all because of 2016
this is all because Donald Trump got
elected president
the Ninth Circuit gave Trump a partial
win and then the Supreme Court gave
Trump of hard full win because of the
2016 election
The Washington Post actually prophesied
this in February they said quote thanks
to trump the liberal 9th circuit is no
longer liberal that's what elections do
and the people who vote for in those
elections and the candidates who run in
those elections don't always get the
credit for it because you just see the
effects of years later I mean already
three years after the 2016 election the
judges matter judges were a big issue in
2016 the judges get lifetime
appointments and now as so much of our
lawmaking process has been outsourced to
the courts been outsourced to not just
the Supreme Court but all the other
courts too when Bush signed
mccain-feingold
the anti first amendment legislation
about campaign finance in in the early
2000s
he said it might be unconstitutional but
he was gonna let the courts decide that
it's not just the courts that have a
duty to uphold the Constitution it's the
executive and it's the legislature too
but they say now we don't want to deal
with it we're gonna put that on the
courts so the courts now have become a
hugely outsized important aspect of our
lawmaking process some anti-trump
conservatives still say 2016 wasn't
worth it
why because Cavanaugh seems a little
squishy you know maybe he's good on
administrative law but he's he's not
gonna be as good on say Roe versus Wade
that's the prediction Kennedy liked him
too much who's one of Kennedy's
hand-picked successors Gorsuch maybe is
a little better who knows but there are
more courts in the country than in the
Supreme Court of the United States the
vast majority of Court decisions are
made at the lower level and yesterday
cocaine Mitch McConnell confirmed his
150th judge since Trump's inauguration
way outpacing Barack Obama who at this
point as presidents he only had 94
judges confirmed in the same amount of
time elections matter you don't win by
losing you don't win by losing Democrats
want to pretend you win by losing that's
the third piece of great news for the
White House today in the most closely
watched elections since the 2018 midterm
elections the GOP went two for two in
North Carolina's big elections out of
North Carolina
most important one was in North
Carolina's ninth congressional district
there was some alleged fraud there in
2018 that caused the State Election
Board to actually call for a new
election there in 2018 the Republican
candidate got 905 more votes than the
Democrat this week the Republican Dan
Bishop beat Democrat Dan McReady 51 to
49 not a huge win but decisive pretty
clear who won that two points is pretty
good in elections especially important
his Dan Bishop is a conservative
lightning rod he is the guy when Obama
started trying to make public schools
all over the country let men go into the
little girls bathroom dan bishop was a
guy who who wrote the bathroom bills in
North Carolina he said no man have to
use the men's room and women have to use
the women's room and grown men can't go
into the little girl
room and this was somehow controversial
here's Dan Bishop on his victory tonight
the voters of North Carolina sent a
message that shouldn't just be heard in
within the confines of the ninth
district it should reverberate across
this country and in the halls of the
Capitol the voters said no to the
radical liberal policies being pushed by
today's Democratic Party tonight was the
first step toward taking back the House
of Representatives in 2020 to keep this
country on a path to prosperity and
Frank he's looking ahead to 2020 saying
look guys we won they said we wouldn't
win we won we won because the the
American people and our voters are fed
up with the left radical cultural
narrative I mean Dan Bishop is the
bathroom bill guy that is a culture
warrior that is a cultural issue and he
still won the left was furious but they
can't concede elections Al Gore can't
concede Hillary Clinton can't concede
Stacy Abrams Andrew Gilliam John Assaf
bado or work
none of them can admit that they lost
they all pretend that they won and so
even though the Democrat Dan McReady
lost really with the way the left is
playing and as they say no no no
secretly he won New York Times mr.
bishops narrow victory over Dan McReady
in a conservative district demonstrated
warning signs for President Trump in
2020 warning signs that will win by two
two points all right works for me 538 on
paper it was Republicans who emerged
victorious going to four two and two
separate congressional elections that's
just on paper but let's see what about
in the fantasy world 538 goes on there
was also a silver lining for Democrats
their final vote margin in the night's
marquee race was much bluer than the
district's baseline partisanship okay
538 points out Trump won the district by
12 points in 2016
okay that was a presidential election
year
Republicans also won in the off year
2018 Republicans also won in the off
year
this wasn't a presidential year wasn't
even an off year it was like a random
special election that was called we
still won so what does this mean for
2020 means Democrats haven't learned any
lessons not terribly much has changed if
and if they're not going to change then
then they can expect the same result as
2016
you know madness is doing the same thing
over and over and over again and
expecting different results you're
seeing this right now big poll before we
get to the mailbag big poll out from
economist YouGov that has Biden and
Warren tied at 26 percent I tend not to
care about national polls even when when
it's in the primary the only reason this
one matters is because Biden's entire
campaign is staked on so-called
electability if Biden is no longer the
top candidate he has no argument to be
elected it's it the campaign goes away
and that's what you're seeing here a new
poll has Warren and Biden at 26% Sanders
at 16% way down by 10 points buta jegeon
Harris at 6% Booker and yang at 2%
everyone else below that at 1% very
interesting poll numbers coming out
before tonight's Democratic presidential
debate should be very interesting to see
I think I'm gonna go on Crowder's show
tonight so you can catch me there during
the debate but I'll be tweeting with
rather the rest of it and we will have a
show tomorrow so we'll get to that then
really bad news for Biden who by the way
if you believe the other polls was the
Democrats best hope at beating President
Trump that hope may be fading very fast
as the Trump administration is getting
lots and lots of wings cultural madness
around us as they turn the frickin
Penguins gay but on the hardline real
politics on the ground things are
looking up we'll get to the mailbag in a
second first I've got a second bite of
Facebook and YouTube go to daily
wire.com you get me you get the under
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get the Matt Walsh show you test
questions in the mailbag coming up you
get another Kingdom which we're gonna be
recording more today it's really really
a great manuscript I think it's the best
installment yet it's gonna be ton of fun
you get backstage you get all this stuff
you get the leftist ears tumblr
now before it's too late in 2020 daily
wire.com will be right back
first question from Ashley what do you
see is happening to the Trump presidency
when he leaves office
I fear that establishment Republicans
will throw his policies under the bus or
do you think Trump has tied his policies
to GOP political success well very
specifically speaking what I see
happening to the Trump presidency when
he leaves office is that it will no
longer be the Trump presidency I guess
that's sort of a truism this is
important because the stuff that we
spend all the time talking about with
the Trump administration is his
personality and that will be gone only
he can do that do you remember in 2016
Marco Rubio tried to do that he tried to
beat rump do a Rickles routine down in
Florida but his small hands doesn't work
only Trump can do that he's an American
original
he is a once-in-a-lifetime pop culture
star and an a-list celeb celebrity too
so that is gonna go away as for the
policies president Trump has done an
incredible thing I tend to be with of
the opinion that Ann Coulter is there's
a bit of a divide on the right some
people think that the American people
voted for Trump because of his
personality despite his policies some
people think that we voted for Trump
because of his policies or because of
his policies despite his personality
does that make sense
you know people some people hate the
tweets but they like what he's doing
some people hate what he's doing or
don't care about what he's doing but
they really like the tweets I very much
believe we elected Trump on substance he
presented something that the other
candidates did not the other candidates
were trying to resurrect the dead bodies
of all the great conservative heroes of
the 80s Ronald Reagan William F Buckley
Jr who helped construct really the whole
post-war conservative movement all of
these guys we were basically trying to
just reanimate their corpses dig them up
from the grave and then just say the
same slogans that they said as though we
were still fighting the Cold War and it
were you know the 90s and the 2000s it
never happened and Trump comes along and
he just gets rid of
that because he wasn't really an
ideological you know Brooks Brothers
wearing typical college conservative
type he's his own guys just a his own
man he's an American original and so he
cleared a lot of that away and opened
the door on questions like trade for
instance it had become for a very short
period of time really just the 80s
through the early 2000s it became
conservative gospel that we had to have
unfettered free trade and globalization
this had never been a conservative
position Russell Kirk in one of the
seminal conservative works the
conservative mind says free trade is
terrible for conservatism conservatives
hate it the Republican Party was founded
against free trade was founded on
tariffs Abraham Lincoln the first
Republican president said give me a
tariff I'll give you the greatest
country in the world it's not by the way
not an argument for tariffs not an
argument against free trade but it's an
argument against is this kind of rigid
ideological attachment to economic
policies and foreign policies of the
1980s that were inextricably tied to the
Soviet Union now the Soviet Union's go
on
we finally woke up and realized hey wait
a second there is a downside to
globalization hey wait a second maybe we
shouldn't export all of our
manufacturing and have it all be
overseas hey wait a second maybe we
should care about the blue blue collar
workers hey wait a second hey wait a
second maybe we are being taken
advantage of on trade deals
maybe our NATO allies should start
actually paying for their own militaries
rather than just criticize us all the
time and wait for Big Daddy America to
come in and protect them hey wait a
second maybe Russia isn't the greatest
threat when you consider China maybe
China isn't our greatest ally and Russia
our greatest enemy he shook all of that
up that ain't going nowhere
that is it is important that we remember
those lessons I think we will because he
exposed and ossified dead Republican
establishment for what it is not having
answers not having appeal and the wise
politicians who follow in Trump's wake
after Trump leaves the White House are
gonna get that they're gonna keep it up
from Michael Michael I'd like to start
getting into great classic novels where
do you suggest I start
which do you think are among the best of
all time funny you're asking me this
rather than Clavin because I actually
don't read a lot of novels
I much prefer reading and philosophy and
theology and nonfiction I like reading
history a lot so I'm not the best guy to
go to though actually in a weird way
maybe I am because you want to start
getting into this reading I'm I'm sort
of an avatar of that you know i I've
read some of the great works but it's
not like drew whose write every single
book that's ever been written I would
begin with my favorite novel
coincidentally it's actually his
favorite novel - Crime and Punishment by
Dostoyevsky it's a wonderful novel about
an ax murderer and you'll think that
he's writing about you and your soul
that's that's a wonderful novel what
other novels do I really like I like a
lot of Italian novels there's one called
the betrothed by Monde Sony that's a
great novel it's going to eat promesa
Sposi in Italian for a good sort of
conservative novel I loved let's see
weathering Heights I like that if you
want a little more romance in your day
I'll have to think on this a little bit
more but start with crime and punishment
start with Dostoyevsky some of the
Russians I think that'll it's a good way
in for people who like nonfiction
because they're dealing with such meaty
philosophical questions from Scottie
Protestant friend of yours here I'm not
against the idea of purgatory because it
does seem to fulfill some theological
questions that some struggle with have
you come across biblical evidence for
purgatory yes yeah here are some
evidence from some 66 now ditz let men
ride over our heads we went through fire
and through water yet thou has brought
us forth to a spacious place now in the
view of origin and st. Ambrose this was
an evidence of purgatory the imagery of
the fire so it is a fire it is a
cleansing and a punishment but it is a a
fire that actually cleanses you and
allows you to go into the spacious place
from Isaiah this was a citation good
enough for st. Agustin in the City of
God Isaiah writes when the Lord shall
have washed away the filth of the
daughters of Zion and
to the bloodstains of Jerusalem from its
midst by a spirit of judgment and by a
spirit of burning here you have the
spirit of judgment the spirit of burning
what is that judgment what is that
burning this is purgatorial language
then you have in second Maccabees which
is a book that Martin Luther took out of
the Bible but at least the Catholics and
the Orthodox still like it and even some
of the Church Fathers who didn't like
what are called the deuterocanonical
books that many Protestant denominations
have taken out of the Bible even they
liked the books there are many of the
books in so much as they were good
reading for catechumens and people
entering the faith they just didn't
think they should be included in the
Canon of the Bible itself but in second
Maccabees you see that pretty clear
evidence of it for if he were not
expecting that those who had fallen
would rise again
it would have been superfluous and
foolish to pray for the dead but if he
was looking for to the splendid reward
that is laid up for those who fall
asleep in godliness it was a wholly
impious thought therefore he made
atonement for the dead that they might
be delivered from their sin so you've
got these people who have died in a
certain sin and yet we on earth are
praying for the dead that there is hope
for them in heaven I mean this is a
clear description of of purgatory this
verse error this this this series of
verses was good enough for Origen st.
Irenaeus st. Ambrose I'm Agustin and st.
Jerome who all viewed this as a
description of purgatory then in the
Gospels themselves you you have Matthew
5:22 but I say to you that everyone who
is angry with his brother shall be
liable to judgment whoever insults his
brother shall be liable to the council
and whoever says you fool or raca shall
be liable to the fire to to the hell of
fire so what you have here are different
kinds of judgment different levels of
judgment different levels of liability
also in Matthew chapter 5 make friends
quickly with your accuser while you are
going with him to court lest your
accuser hand you over to the judge and
the judge to the guard and you'll be put
in prison truly I say to you you will
never get out till you have paid the
last penny so you will get out you're in
this sort of spirit
prison you will get out but you must pay
the last penny this is a very
purgatorial language also in Matthew
chapter 12 whoever says a word against
the Son of Man will be forgiven but
whoever speaks against the Holy Spirit
will not be forgiven either in this age
or in the age of come different
different sorts of in the age to come
these are sort of different sorts of
sins and then this is probably the
clearest description of it among those
of us who believe in purgatory from
first Corinthians from st. Paul for no
other foundation can anyone lay than
that which is laid which is Jesus Christ
now if anyone builds on the foundation
with gold silver precious stones wood
hay straw each man's work will become
manifest for the day will disclose it
because it will be revealed with fire
and the fire will test what sort of work
each one has done if the work which any
man has built on the foundation survives
he will receive a reward if any man's
work is burned up he will suffer loss
though he himself will be saved but only
as through fire this makes certain
people who deny our participation in the
divine scheme and those who deny the
existence of purgatory and those who
deny the particular judgment this makes
them very uncomfortable because here you
have the language of work here you have
the language of burning up and here you
have the language being saved but only
as through fire so to me to this lay
person who is not a great theologian who
is not a really even a competent
apologist it seems to me that the
scriptural evidence for purgatory is
overwhelming and there is a great
tradition of our our understanding of
purgatory and of course scripture tells
us to listen to the tradition to listen
to what we we have been told as well so
that even even that even non scriptural
tradition is a scriptural tradition and
so it seems to me that the case for
purgatory is quite sound in the case
against purgatory is pretty weak let's
try to take one more question from
Candace is it true that your wife is a
doctor so funny you ask that Candace my
wife is a doctor doctor sweet little
Alisa God
her PhD last week she is a doctor now I
should clarify she's not a physician
she's a doctor so doctor is a Latin word
it means teacher doctor comes from the
Latin verb Doh cherry she now has her
PhD her doctorate and then she may teach
because she's in the Academy
so she's a doctor some people get this
confused you know with like surgeons and
physicians and stuff but anyway my wife
is a doctor yes indeed that's our show
we'll be back tomorrow after the debate
enjoy it tonight
in the meantime I'm Michael nose this is
the Michael Nolt show I'll see you then
because I don't like gay people I don't
like her putting chemicals in the water
stick turn the friggin frogs gay do you
understand that
crap
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director
Pavel why douse key edited by Danny
D'Amico audio is mixed by Mike core
Amina hair and makeup is by Jessa alvera
and our production assistant is Nick
Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19 on the Matt Walsh oh we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation